oh that is so Gotham
[Music]
so Gotham is back and I am a little bit
late on this long story short just when
the first episode premiered I just had a
lot of crap going on it wasn't able to
get to it right away and unfortunately I
had stuff for the docket immediately
following that and to try and catch up
on the episode after missing it the day
I I had intended to would have just
thrown the entire schedule off so I
opted instead to wait a week do a double
review so I am for this one gonna talk
about the two most recent episodes those
being pieces of a broken mirror and a
beautiful darkness and honestly I'm kind
of glad I did these back-to-back because
the first one of the two is not bad but
felt like a weak opener and I mean I do
say open it because I the way Gotham
tends to go is it has a pretty sizable
mid-season finale right before the show
goes on hiatus and it's very much a
wrapping up of whatever the the through
line had been up to that point so this
is like starting a whole new story and
it's not it's not a particularly strong
start and a lot of it has to do with
their stuff that I'm not entirely sure
either why they did it or why it's there
so in terms of like stuff I don't know
why time is eaten up with Alfred and
this woman that he you know meets likes
tries to protect dies he goes after the
boyfriend who killed her
I again it's not bad and I loved Sean
Pertwee but I don't know why it's there
I don't know why it's in the episode
other than just to like keep tabs on on
Alfred I guess Ivy is back finally God
that took forever
apparently she's just been a pod in a
pod in that in that store for this whole
time I'll be blunt about it I don't like
the new ivy
and the thing is first of all I enjoyed
the previous Ivey quite a bit and I
didn't like a little girl ivy I didn't
see what the point of her was when they
jacked up her age honestly she started
working really well for me not an
immediate leonitia it was like I'm not
so sure about this but I was really
enjoying her by the time they had her
wrap up and I'm watching this new
actress play the part and I'm left
thinking I don't understand what it is
about this performance or what's being
required of the character that meant we
had to get rid of the last ivy like I
understood
prior to this with the age jump because
what they decided they were going to do
with the character she was just flat out
too young so I got that one this one
though I don't get it I don't understand
what it is about this angle must be done
that that requires a move forward I get
that her personality and her goals have
kind of refocused she's much she's much
more fanatical about you know plants the
environment and all that but you don't
need to change the actress in order to
do that she's been out of commission a
long time you could have that same
actress we had before come out of the
pod and like with just some different
look green detailing makeup in the face
or something you know to indicate a
change but this again I don't I don't
see what we gained and I did like that
previous ivy the previous ivy especially
had really good on-screen chemistry with
Selene on this new one does not so we'll
see what happens we'll see how it goes
but I'm not that move I I do not care
for and I don't particularly think was a
was a great idea some of the other stuff
going on i hiddens of the riddler coming
back which I'm good with part of me is
like cuz you know there's something
about putting characters through cycles
like they move forward but then they go
back to what they
did I but he plays it really well I have
a lot of fun with him playing it like
that so that works for me
penguin being in the I'm just kind of
jumped between these two episodes I'm
not gonna like do a clear dividing line
so some of the stuff most of the more
positive stuff that I Rose is in the
second one but penguin being the asylum
with Jerome that's that was a that was
quite a delightful thing I you know what
I like about Jerome and and as I say
this I'm going to say yes
I did read the thing with her saying
were they're still saying he might not
be the Joker just the precursor to
someone who influences the guy who will
eventually become the Joker I'm still
got to think of him as the Joker
regardless but what I like about this
sort of take on that character is with
any good version of the Joker you need
to pick what you're going to emphasize
because the Joker can be interpreted a
heck of a lot of different ways he can
be a playful pricks you have prankster
and a trickster which was kind of the
Cesar Romero sort of thing you can get
you can really embrace the agent of
chaos which was what Heath Ledger did
you had Jack Nicholson you're pulling in
the psychotic gangster elements then
that worked pretty well what I like
about Jerome is the emphasis here is on
the showmanship and the theatricality of
it this guy loves to put on a show and I
think that was a that was a good point
of emphasis to do on this particular
interpretation of the character so I'll
be curious to see where things go with
him that will definitely be interesting
butch getting his sort of personality
and his memory back I don't know I'll
see where it goes I'm still liking
Leslie in the Narrows and you know as
the dark dumb as that sounds but I do
appreciate her in that role I like what
she's doing I like that I see what she's
trying to do for the people there but I
still can't quite nail down how she
feels towards Gordon and I'd like that
Sofia Falcone is just kind of there at
this point and I'm not not sure there
was actually although you know what I
really did enjoy Bruce's hallucination
when Ivy poisoned it well first of all
nice acknowledgement that she says this
is gonna kill you slower because I want
you to suffer so that was a nice
acknowledgement of the fact that this is
not gonna kill him anywhere near as fast
as we've seen up to this point so I
appreciate that but I genuinely enjoyed
that hallucination pretty much all of it
and I can't tell you why because I know
that it's cheesy and kind of cheap I
really dug the gravel-voiced shadowy
Batman part of that vision there's
something about him seeing this thing
like scuttling up walls and it leaps at
him and it's and it's got the voice and
I really liked it that put a huge smile
on my face and I'm not entirely sure why
cuz it should have been cheesy but it's
it's working for me and I think it was a
good time to pull the trigger on on
something like that because you know the
the first of these two episodes he's
still in you know running up the tab at
the at the club and just partying all
night mode which I get why he's in that
in that place um but I was ready for
that to be over and it looks like it
looks like these shows now ready for it
to be over - so I'm a okay with that I
think that's just about it these two
episodes were well I like this I go on
better which I mentioned they were
pretty good I am interested in what
they're setting up and what's coming
next in and of themselves they're not
amazing so far I really do they
the season fours strong point was the
pig storyline and all of that most of
the rest of it has been pretty good
pretty decent with a couple of highlight
episodes here and there but I am gonna
be curious as we get into the home
stretch I am a little bit worried that
Ivy's gonna be kind of overly front and
center I'm kind of hoping she gets
wrapped up in the next couple of
episodes and maybe we can put the focus
on Jerome instead I have a feeling
that's probably gonna be the other way
around but we'll see
so Gotham's back I'm watching it I'm
reviewing it did you see the latest
episodes what did you think about them
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it do all the stuff do the
likes and the subscribes and the support
me on patreon perhaps links for all this
stuff
and more is down in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]